So you may be thinking, "How does Santa get around the whole world in one night?"
Let's say that Santa needs to visit every one of the two billion children in the world.
The average home has two and a half children,...
...so that means he has to visit around 800 million homes.
Because it becomes night at different times all around the globe,...
...he actually has 48 hours to deliver all the presents.
So that means he needs to get to around five houses every single second.
The most likely explanation is that he uses an antimatter rocket on the back of his sleigh.
Antimatter has the opposite charge to normal matter.
And when they combine together, they create a huge explosion of energy,...
...blasting the sleigh forward at nearly the speed of light.
NASA is studying this to use in their rocket engines,...
...but it looks like Santa has already beaten them to it.